ارحب بكم من متحف يضم بين جدرانه بعض اقدم
السيارات في العالم والسياره اختراع غير
عالمنا وعاداتنا اليوميه ومنحنا حريه في
التنقل والسفر فماذا نعرف عن تاريخ
السياره وكيف تطورت على مر الزمن لحظات
ويرفع الستار اهلا بكم في اسرار باريس
[موسيقى]
اقف الان امام سياره اسطوريه سياره دو
شوفو التي تم تصنيعها على مدار عقود في
فرنسا منتصف القرن العشرين كانت السياره
المفضله لاطباء الريف وسعاد البريد وحتى
كهنه الضياع لكن تاريخ السياره لم يبدا في
القرن الماضي اكتشفوا ابرز محطاته في هذا
التقرير
على دروب فرنسا هذا الصباح اعربه فريده من
نوعها لا تجرها الخيل ولا البغال تحمل
غلايه ضخمه تنفذ غيمه من البخار نحن عام
1770 وهذه عربه النار اول سياره في
التاريخ مخترعها نيكولا كينيو يقدمها
كبديلا عن الاحصنه لنقل العتاد الحربي لكن
التجارب الاولى غير مشجعه لا سيما وان
سرعتها لا تتخطى سرعه رجل يسير على الاقد
ام وعربه
بخاري تلزمه زهاء ساعه حتى يبدا بتشغيل
العجله
فالسيارات الاولى تعمل على البخار ولن
تنافسها الا نهايه القرن التاسع عشر
سيارات بمحرك الانفجاري يغذيه وقود سائل
او غزي
وهكذا عام
1885 اخترع الالماني كارل بانس اول سياره
بمفهومنا الحديث تعمل بمحرك فجاري ومع
ناقل للحركه اختراع جلب الشهره لصاحبه
وكان حجر الاساس لما سيصبح فيما بعد شركه
مرسيدس بنز الشهيره اوائل القرن العشرين
كان اكثر من 30 مصنعا فرنسيا يتباهون
بابتكاراتهم في المعرض السنوي للسيارات
وفي طليعاتهم ثلاث شركات غونو
لكن سياره امريكيه ستقلب كل المعايير
سياره فورد التي لم يكن يتخطى ثمنها 850
دولارا
مصنعها هند ريفورد ارادها في متناول
الجميع فاعتمد انتاجا تسلسليا مع خطوط
تجميع تصنع سياره كل اربعه وعشرين ثانيه
مع اندلاع الحرب العالميه الثانيه تعرضت
عده مصانع للسيارات للقصف والدمار كما فكك
الالمان خلال احتلالهم لفرنسا اجزاء من
مصانع بيجو لينتج بدل السيارات قطعا
لصاروخهم الشهير
وصادر الجيش النازي ايضا مصانع التي عهدت
ادارتها الى شركه ديملو بانس الالمانيه
بعد التحرير اتحمت السلطات الفرنسيه مؤسسه
غنو
بالتعامل مع العدو فجرا سجنه وتاميم شركته
[موسيقى]
رغم هذه الصعوبات نجح المصنعون الفرنسيون
في غضون خمس سنوات بعد الحرب في ابتكار
طرازات جديده خلافا لمنافسيهم الاوروبيين
فبعد سنتين من التامين نهضت شركه هونو من
كبوتها مع سياره رينو 4 التي عرفت شعبيه
واسعه لانها كانت تلائم كل الميزانيه
وخلال الفتره ذاتها ذكرت شركه سيتخوان
سياره دوشو الشهيره التي اصبحت مع خبز
الباقات وبرج ايفل رمزا من رموز فرنسا
اليوم يدخلها هذا القطاع مرحله جديده مع
سيارات اكثر امنا ومراعاه للصحه وللبيئه
فالسياره الحديثه اشبه بحاسوب ضخم يحذركم
من مخاطر عديده واذا كانت العربه بدون خيل
امرا مستهجلا قبل قرن فقد يصبح السائق خلف
مقوده امرا اكثر استهجانا في السنوات
القادمه
[موسيقى]
نحن الان على بعد ساعتين من باريس وفي
مدينه تعتبر عاصمه سباقات السيارات في
العالم مدينه لو غرب فرنسا فتاريخ السياره
مرتبط بتاريخ السباقات التي سمحت بفعل
التنافس بتحسين اداء السياره وسرعتها
وتعزيز سلامه السائقين قصه اشهر السباقات
نرويها لكم في هذا التقرير
سباق للسيارات مطلع القرن العشرين هذه
المشاهد تخلد بعض اولى السباقات في
التاريخ وقتها كانت غلبيتها تنطلق من
باريس وتجري على طرقات مغلقه مناسبه
للمصنعين لاختبار ابتكاراتهم التكنولوجيه
والتباري مع منافسيهم في الميدان اول سباق
للسيارات جرى في فرنسا بين مدينه باريس
وغوا عام
1894 هذا السباق لاعربات للمره الاولى
بدون خيل لم يكن يقيس سرعه المتسابقين بل
كان يكافئ عربه امنه سهله الاستعمال وبسعر
معقول فاسرع سياره في السباق بالكاد تخطت
العشرين كيلو مترا في الساعه
كما ظهر للمره الاولى خلال سباق
واختراع جديد المقود على احدى سيارات
تيباغ الفرنسيه
سنه
1911 ولد اعرق ريلي للسيارات في العالم
ريموت كارلو الذي يتميز بمسار على طرقات
جبليه متعرجه معظمها في فرنسا وفي ظروف
شتويه صعبه بما انه ينظم دوما في شهر
يناير رغم ذلك فان رالي مونت كارلو لن
يكون الاصعب هذا اللقب سيصف ابتداء من عام
سباقا اخر
سباق 24 ساعه فكما يدل عليه اسمه يدوم هذا
السباق يوما كاملا ويختبر القدره على
التحمل وقد سمح سباق لماماهم بتحسين اداء
السيارات بشكل عام واختبار الابتكارات
الجديده
[موسيقى]
بين ان حادثا مروعا عام
1955 القى بظلال ثقيله على هذه
هذا الحدث هو الاسوء في عالم سباقات
السيارات وقع عندما ارتطمت سياره مرسيدس
بجوار امام المنصه الرئيسيه خلال سباق 24
ساعه ما ادى الى انفجار كبير تتغيرت على
اثره اجزاء من السياره فقتل اكثر من 80
شخصا من الجمهور اضافه الى سائق المرسيدس
فعالم سباقات السيارات ميدان ترعاه قوانين
صارمه لكنه بفعل السرعه يغازل الخطر في كل
لحظه ولو كان خلف المقود بطل الابطال
[موسيقى]
الان في معرض مخصص لتاريخ السياره في
المعهد الوطني للحرف والمهن
ويستقبلنا هنا مدير هذا المعرض السيد
ليونيل ديفو للتطرق الى حوادث السير
الاولى في التاريخ والحديث عن تطور
السلامه المروريه وظهور رخصه القياده
موبيلا
[موسيقى]
يعني
الى بالي
[موسيقى]
بهذا ناتي الى ختامي هذه الحلقه عن تاريخ
السيارات من متحف السيارات في مدينه
في حلقه جديده من اسرار باريس
[موسيقى]